mes chers collègues je vous propose que
nous commençons notre audition
avec mon collègue Serge babary
madame la ministre monsieur le président
de la Délégation aux entreprises chers
barbarie mes chers collègues c'est un
plaisir de vous retrouver voilà en
session maintenant régulière c'est la
première fois madame la ministre que la
commission des affaires économiques et
la délégation aux entreprises du Sénat
vous entendent en format plénière depuis
votre nomination et les sujets sont
extrêmement nombreux puisque les
secteurs du commerce de l'artisanat du
tourisme sont bien sûr fondamentaux et
structurels pour toute notre économie je
sais que vous aimez dire que c'est
beaucoup beaucoup d'entreprises dont on
ne parle pas suffisamment pas beaucoup
beaucoup or il faut bien le dire ces
entreprises ne font que trop rarement la
une de l'actualité alors qu'elles
irriguent nos territoires et notre
quotidien ces secteurs font face de
longue date à des enjeux extrêmement
importants qui s'accentue avec le temps
particulièrement dans la période
actuelle bien sûr nous parlerons de la
drastique des factures d'énergie mais
nous pourrons aussi parler si vous le
souhaitez la problématique de
recrutement de la fiscalité l'inégalité
concurrentielle un certain nombre de
sujets qui sont au cœur des thèmes sur
lesquels nous travaillons ici au Sénat
et pour lesquels nous serons intéressés
de connaître votre analyse la commission
des affaires économiques a publié ces
deux dernières années plusieurs rapports
sur ces sujets notamment à l'initiative
de mon collègue Serge gabarit qui visait
tout autant à adapter notre pays aux
nouvelles formes de commerce qui a
sauvegardé développé le commerce en zone
rurale il en est de même pour la
délégation aux entreprises qui s'est
penchée sur les sujets de RSE de
compétences ou plus récemment sur
l'évolution des modes de travail
peut-être pourrez-vous nous indiquer si
vous avez vu lui regarder ses
propositions et qu'elles suite vous
pensez éventuellement y donner l'un des
enjeux les plus importants qui
préoccupent les PME à court terme bien
sûr dans alimentation très importante de
leur charge au premier rang desquels les
charges de gaz d'électricité lors du
renouvellement de leur contrat
d'approvisionnement cette situation les
contraints à rogner leur marge bien sûr
si elles en ont encore ce que font 80
pratiquement 90% des PME soit augmenter
leur prix soit les deux d'ailleurs soit
quelques fois à licencier voire
peut-être pire votre présence permettra
notamment de faire le point sur les
dispositifs de protection tarifaires qui
ont déjà été mis en place par le
gouvernement et peut-être ce que vous
envisagez pour la suite un moyen terme
le secteur du commerce fait lui aussi
face à l'ensemble de défis
particulièrement contraignants la
différence de fiscalité entre le
commerce numérique et le commerce
physique avec bien sûr des forces qui ne
doivent pas s'opposer qui doivent être
complémentaires mais une concurrence qui
n'est pas toujours très loyale et donc
nous vous interrogerons sur que va-t-il
se passer
des conclusions des Assises du commerce
qui ont été faits opportunément voici un
an mais dont nous attendons les
conclusions et bien sûr les actions qui
s'ensuivent autre élément qui concerne
le commerce qui a fait l'objet de
l'actualité cet été l'histoire des Dark
Store et voilà qui envahit l'ensemble de
nos grandes villes pour l'instant je dis
grande ville pour l'instant bien sûr
parce que leur développement reste à
venir
pourriez-vous nous confirmer qu'elle est
finalement la position du gouvernement
entre commerce et entrepôts est-ce que
c'est de façon durable et comment est-ce
que nous allons pouvoir peut-être mettre
un peu de régulation dans tout ça en
tout cas d'équité dans le développement
de cette dark score est-ce que c'est une
exonérable est-ce qu'on doit réguler ce
qu'on doit là aussi apporter quelques
facteurs d'équité voilà votre avis
évidemment intéressant autre sujet qui
relève de vos attributions qui sont
nombreuses madame la ministre la fonte
des effectifs de la DGCCRF je suis sûr
que vous aurez des sénateurs qui vous
interrogeront sur ce sujet
en matière de contrôle de l'information
apportée aux consommateurs la DGCCRF par
exemple ne dispose plus que de 145 ETP
soit une baisse de 14 % par rapport à
2010 comme le rapport de Fabien guet de
Françoise Ferrat que je qui est là-bas
voilà et de Florence blatrix compta la
montrer récemment voilà qui est là
pardon Florence au niveau régional il y
a ainsi qu'un seul inspecteur dans les
hauts de France par exemple 8
inspecteurs en Bretagne 11 pour le grand
est sans surprise sur la dernière
décennie le nombre de contrôles ABC de
30%, cette situation est difficilement
autonome pour nous entreprises qui font
face à des fraudes et pour les
consommateurs eux-mêmes est-ce que vous
pouvez nous indiquer quelles sont vos
intentions concernant la DGCCRF soit sur
les objectifs soit sur des nouveau
dispositif de contrôle des informations
et de la qualité des produits mis sur le
marché enfin pour terminer deux sujets
très importants le premier qui concerne
puisque vous êtes le ministre du
Commerce je voudrais vous interroger sur
les renégociations commerciales entre
fournisseurs et distributeurs vous savez
que c'est un cauchemar pour tout le
monde pour les industriels mais aussi je
crois pour les distributeurs comme vous
le savez le rapport de Daniel Gremillet
d'Anne Catherine Loisier de juillet à
pointe du toit des pratiques
contestables de la part des différentes
parties allant de la hausse des prix en
rayon sans hausse de tarif d'achat aux
menaces de rupture d'approvisionnement
le travail qui est mené par votre
ministère
colopartile c'est constat qu'elle
regarde portez-vous sur ces négociations
annuelles et enfin comment tout cela va
évoluer et puis dernier sujet qui m'est
venu dans l'après-midi voilà d'une
audition que j'ai faite et que j'ai
rajouté
nous avons je crois vous avez le
gouvernement demandé voici quelques
temps un rapport de plusieurs
inspections
[Musique]
merci Sophie madame la ministre madame
la Présidente chers collègues je partage
bien sûr les préoccupations relayées par
la présidente Sophie prima je voudrais
de façon complémentaire centrée mes
propos sur la situation des ETI PME et
TPE qui sont au cœur du champ de
compétence de la délégation aux
entreprises que je préside ainsi que du
vôtre madame la ministre notre
délégation a organisé une table ronde
sur la conjoncture économique voici deux
semaines avec les représentants des
organisations professionnelles vous le
savez leur inquiétude est extrême et
nous craignons que le gouvernement ne
sous-estime le tourbillon vicieux en
train de sérieusement saper l'activité
économique dans notre pays alors que
tous les voyants passent à l'orange
quand ce n'est pas au rouge nombre
d'entreprises voient leurs marges
engloutie par la hausse des coûts et
certaines travaillent même à perte
d'après ce qui remonte de nos
départements
beaucoup doivent ou devront réduire leur
production voir l'emploi à l'occasion
d'un déplacement dans le Lot-et-Garonne
en fin de semaine dernière des
dirigeants de TPE et PME se sont
inquiétés du manque de prévisibilité
même à 2 ou 3 mois on vit dans le flou
et la peur des coupures à témoigner l'un
d'entre eux
outre ces sujets je souhaite attirer
votre attention sur le rapport adopté
jeudi dernier conjointement par les
délégations sénatoriales aux
collectivité territoriales et aux
entreprises sur la revitalisation des
centres-villes et centre bourg parmi nos
recommandations relatives à
l'application de la loi Elan et des
programmes actions cœur de ville et
petites villes de demain figurent la
lutte contre la bureaucratisation et la
complexité des dispositifs ainsi qu'un
financement à la hauteur des attentes et
des enjeux
madame la ministre nous espérons que
vous pourrez avec vos autres collègues
concernés prendre en compte nos
propositions
qu'on vous présentera d'ailleurs si vous
le souhaitez directement la délégation
aux entreprises adoptera par ailleurs ce
jeudi un rapport sur la transmission
d'entreprise puis le 27 octobre un
rapport de suivi sur le RSE sachant que
les PME s'inquiètent à juste titre nous
semble-t-il des modalités d'application
des directives européennes CSRD et sur
le devoir de vigilance il est toucheront
directement ou indirectement enfin nous
nous penchons au chevet de notre
commerce extérieur je pense que nos
rapporteurs sur ces sujets vous poseront
quelques questions je voudrais conclure
en évoquant la situation des champs
consulaires puisque vous exercez par
délégation la tutelle des champs le
commerce et d'industrie ainsi que des
chambres de métiers de l'artisanat alors
que leur mission s'accroisent que leur
action sur le territoire est encore plus
essentiel et apprécié dans le contexte
des cris successifs que nous connaissons
leurs moyens sont rognés la cohérence
nous échappe et nous aimerions vous sur
ce sujet également la dame la ministre
nous devons maintenant la parole puis
nos collègues vous poseront certainement
quelques questions je vous remercions
par avance pour nos échanges que nous
espérons fructueux
je sens l'énergie à côté de moi Madame
la Ministre à vous
merci madame la Présidente prima
monsieur le président babary mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs bonsoir c'est un
sincère plaisir de vous retrouver et un
grand honneur de venir parler avec vous
du périmètre large effectivement dont
j'ai l'honneur et la charge au sein du
gouvernement les petites et les moyennes
entreprises le commerce l'artisanat le
tourisme mais je ne souhaiterais pas
oublier les indépendants les professions
libérales et la consommation
et donc pas la concurrence
néanmoins je veux vraiment prendre
quelques minutes et vous m'excuser par
avance parce que compte tenu de du
périmètre de ce portefeuille qui est
très large je serai volontairement assez
lacunaire dans mon propos introductif
l'idée étant qu'on ait du temps pour les
changes plus que moi dans le monologue
s'il fallait résumer les sujets dont
j'ai la charge je dirais effectivement
madame la Présidente prima que j'ai
l'honneur d'être la ministre de
l'économie de proximité une économie
comme vous l'avez très bien dit qu'il ne
fait pas la une des journaux du moins
pas assez journaux sont plus trustés par
les startups et les grands groupes mais
c'est une économie qui à défaut de faire
la une des journaux fait la une de nos
quotidiens
nos quotidiens à tous
c'est le restaurant où on aime se
retrouver c'est le boulanger dont nous
ne manquerons pas de parler et qui
connaît beaucoup de difficultés
aujourd'hui c'est aussi
l'avocat le comptable qui accompagne nos
PME et
ça n'est pas à vous elle cherche
sénateur que j'apprendrai l'importance
de cette économie de proximité cette
économie de tous les jours c'est 4
millions de petits et moyennes
entreprises qui représentent c'est
toujours important de le rappeler pas
moins de
99,8 % des entreprises en France près de
la moitié de nos emplois salariés en
équivalent en temps plein et plus de 40%
de la valeur ajoutée qui est créée dans
ce pays
économie de la proximité c'est aussi une
économie de la complexité j'ai pas peur
de le reconnaître
une boulangerie n'a pas les mêmes enjeux
qu'une agence de tourisme de même qu'un
grand magasin spécialisé peut
difficilement se comparer à un cabinet
d'avocat et pourtant économiquement il
relève tous du ministère dont j'ai la
charge et je crois que le fil rouge a
tiré entre les différents publics cibles
de ce ministère c'est précisément
celui-là aider les acteurs économiques
du quotidien à affronter je n'ai pas
peur du mot la complexité de leur
environnement administratif alors qu'ils
ont les yeux rivés sur le carnet de
commandes et le tableau de trésorerie
il y a quelques années on prétendait que
le développement des entreprises en
France étaient par le mur de
l'argent
je crois qu'aujourd'hui grâce notamment
à l'action résolu qui a été menée durant
le premier quinquennat en termes de
fiscalité par exemple avec la Ford baise
de l'impôt sur les sociétés mais aussi
avec le début de la baisse des impôts de
production en termes de financement
aussi avec le soutien de BPI France que
nous avons quand même plutôt fait tomber
ce mur de l'argent auquel beaucoup de
nos petites entreprises étaient
confrontées il ne faudrait pas qu'au mur
de l'argent viennent apparaissent un
nouveau mur un nouveau mur qui pourrait
venir freiner la croissance de nos
entreprises un mur des complications
bureaucratiques un mur qui empêcherait
ou découragerait d'aller chercher des
aides
un mur que faciliterait notre passion
pour les jardins à la française passion
que je partage évidemment avec vous tous
ma conviction c'est que l'État doit être
un facilitateur je veux ici travailler
saluer le travail accompli par Bruno Le
Maire et mes prédécesseur
évidemment Jean-Baptiste Lemoine au
cours de la crise du covid ou
précisément nous avons dû démontrer
ensemble notre capacité à faire simple à
faire vite et surtout toutes
l'efficacité de nos administrations et
nos agents trop facilement décrits on
peut toujours améliorer les choses on
peut aussi se féliciter de l'expérience
que nous avons eu en tout cas de ce qui
a été fait au service de nos entreprises
et oui la crise actuelle sur les prix de
l'énergie soulignent combien nous avons
encore besoin de cette étape
facilitateur
je crois comme vous
je croise comme vous tous les jours des
chefs d'entreprise qui attendent avec
angoisse le moment où ils vont devoir
renégocier leur contrat auprès de leurs
fournisseurs
nous travaillons dessus
chaque jour à Bercy nous l'avons fait
des cet été vous le savez avec le paquet
pouvoir d'achat nous le faisons en ce
moment même en étant en plus qu'attentif
à toutes les entreprises et en
particulier au plus petites d'entre
elles me concernant qui subirait un
déséquilibre trop important si
l'augmentation des prix est un fait il
n'est pas question qu'elle devienne une
fatalité
comment venir aux aides aux petites
entreprises face à la montée des prix de
l'énergie je ne doute pas que nous y
reviendrons mais je souhaite quand même
en préambule rappeler quelques points
importants rappelez que cette crise est
conjoncturelle
rappeler que les prix finiront par
baisser et c'est à dire que nous
retrouverons les prix d'avant ce n'est
pas le sens de mon propos
dire que cette crise est aussi pour
partie structurelle le prix des énergies
fossiles je crois qu'il faut se le dire
seront durablement plus élevés et
peut-être même pour toujours que les
prix que nous avons connues
conjoncturellement l'État est au
rendez-vous nous avons bloqué les prix
du gaz et de l'électricité au bénéfice
d'un million et demi de TPE qui sont au
TRV tarif réglementé ce bouclier sera
encore intégralement prolongé en 2023
nous avons également annoncé les aides
résilients ainsi que le PG résilient
deux outils ou l'état vient directement
en aide aux entreprises les plus
affectées par la hausse des prix le
décret je ne doute pas que vous l'avez
vu qui assouplit les critères des aides
résilients séparus ce week-end et tient
compte des difficultés qui ont été
exprimées par les entreprises depuis mon
arrivée à Bercy notamment concernant le
BE
de plus avec Bruno Le Maire Agnès panier
ruacher et Roland Lescure nous
continuons à travailler avec les
producteurs et les fournisseurs
d'énergie pour trouver des mesures
pouvant être mises en œuvre rapidement
au service de notre tissu économique je
veux vous dire que nous les réunirons
les fournisseurs d'énergie à nouveau
demain matin à Bercy
structurellement le gouvernement est
aussi dans l'action d'une part le
président de la République l'a dit avec
force et je ne peux que le redire nous
sommes en négociation avec nos
partenaires européens Bruno Le Maire est
en ce moment même à Luxembourg dans ce
cadre
il y a eu un accord vendredi dernier 30
septembre concernant la contribution
exceptionnelle sur les profits des
entreprises du secteur de l'énergie qui
réalise des projets majeurs dans le
contexte actuel
et cet accord sur la contribution des
profits des entreprises sera pour partir
reversée au ménage mais aussi aux
entreprises confrontées à l'explosion
des prix les négociations se poursuivent
pour faire baisser les prix de gros du
gaz dans les tous prochains jours
possiblement lors du sommet du 7 octobre
à Prague ou des ministres de l'énergie
des 11 ou 12 octobre
d'autre part la loi protège déjà les TPE
de moins de 10 salariés dans le CA est
inférieur à 2 millions d'euros
pour leur site qui utilisent pas plus de
36 qui le volts en Pampers ils sont
éligibles au TRV et bénéficie donc du
bouclier tarifaire
au moment même où je suis en train de
vous parler nous regardons nous faisons
plus que regarder nous essayons de créer
les conditions pour que davantage
d'entreprises soient couvertes par un
mécanisme analogue je ne prétendrai pas
devant vous mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs que les problèmes sont réglés
je pense en revanche mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs qui sont traités avec le
degré monsieur le Président babary de
préoccupations dont vous avez témoigné
je reste extrêmement attentif aux
remontez de terrain s'il fallait le cas
échéant encore adapté notre réponse la
conviction que je souhaite partager avec
vous c'est que l'État a démontré ses
capacités d'adaptation et que l'État
sera toujours prêt à bouger pour
protéger ses entreprises
protéger nos petites entreprises ça veut
dire les aider à franchir la montagne
mais certainement pas leur faire croire
que la montagne n'existe pas
la hausse des prix de l'énergie elle
doit pas être vu comme un simple mauvais
moment à passer
je dirais que c'est un moment à dépasser
parce qu'à l'heure du changement
climatique nous ne pourrons dans tous
les cas pas prétendre revenir un jour à
la consommation à la surconsommation à
la production que nous connaissions hier
nous faisons en effet face à un
ajustement rapide d'un prix que nous
avons eu tendance à considérer comme un
acquis depuis de trop nombreuses années
pour ne pas parler de trop nombreuses
décennies ce prix très bas nous a un peu
collectivement fait oublier que le gaz
l'électricité avait un coût ce coût
c'est celui de choix géopolitique et
écologique et puisqu'il s'agit dans un
cas comme dans l'autre de ressources
étrangères et rares y compris pour la
France qui est pourtant mieux protégé
que ses voisins grâce à sa production
nucléaire je serai jeudi aux côtés de la
première ministre pour présenter les
résultats de nos travaux sur la sobriété
aux côtés des acteurs du commerce de
détails de la grande distribution de
l'hôtellerie du commerce de la
restauration de l'événementiel des parcs
à thèmes des commerces de gros du
thermalisme du ski je présenterai les
résultats de nos concertations depuis
plusieurs mois qui permettent ensemble
d'anticiper d'éventuelles difficultés
dans notre approvisionnement en gaz et
en électricité je les dis à ces acteurs
je vous le dis la sobriété ne doit pas
être une mode passagère c'est au
contraire je le crois profondément le
début de la transformation profonde de
nos modèles du modèle de toutes nos
entreprises vers la neutralité carbone
j'en viens donc ici au cœur de ma
feuille de route
l'adaptation de nos entreprises au
changement climatique je dis bien toutes
nos entreprises y compris le
restaurateur le plombier qui sont
pourtant c'est indéniable infiniment
moins émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
que ne sont de grandes industries mais
la transition écologique à énergétique
c'est l'affaire de tous pour plusieurs
raisons
d'abord parce qu'elle impose une
transformation de tous nos modèles et
pas uniquement d'une partie d'entre eux
ensuite parce que les consommateurs
exigent ce changement autant des grands
groupes que des petites entreprises
aussi parce que les talents les jeunes
les salariés d'aujourd'hui et demain
sont de plus en plus sensibles à ces
éléments et qu'au-delà d'être un enjeu
de compétitivité c'est un enjeu
d'attractivité majeur pour nos PME que
de prendre le virage de la transition
environnementale et sociale sénateur
babary j'y reviendrai vous avez
mentionné et vous connaissez ma
tendresse pour la directive CSRD et je
veux dire aussi à cet endroit que oui la
réglementation progresse
non nous n'avons pas à nous faire peur
pour rien
non nos PME au sens français du terme et
notez pe encore moins ne sont pas
directement concernés par la directive
CSRD ça va toujours mieux en le disant
cette réglementation
CSRD votait à l'unanimité au Conseil
Compétitivité du 24 février dernier
concernera toutes les entreprises de
plus de 250 salariés à peu près 11000
aujourd'hui en Europe 50000 demain mais
pas nos PME pour autant et vous avez
raison monsieur le président de la
délégation elles seront indirectement
possiblement concernés par cette
directive parce qu'elles sont au cœur
des chaînes de sous-traitance parce que
les directions des achats de plus en
plus des grandes entreprises des
industries des ETI commencent déjà en
à faire contrôler leur ligne de
sous-traitance et vérifier que
l'ensemble des fournisseurs peu importe
leur rang soit susceptibles de disposer
d'un bilan carbone et donc de montrer
leur décarbonations en cours et donc oui
vous avez raison monsieur le sénateur
barbarie il est indispensable que la
sobriété ne soit pas une mode mais
permettent en réalité de faire levier
dans nos TPE dans nos PME pour installer
à hauteur de TPME la transition
environnementale le cas échéant je ne
suis pas du genre à me cacher derrière
mon petit doigt il est vrai que la
performance extra-financière qui
deviendra la norme ici 2025 pourrait le
cas échéant si nos TPME n'ont pas de
diagnostic environnementaux et sociaux
no TPME pourrait être évincé dans
certains nombre de marchés en tant que
sous-traitante et ce serait à mon sens
un risque systémique qui nous font
anticiper avec beaucoup de précisions
je sais que la délégation sénatoriale
aux entreprises regarde avec vigilance
ces évolutions et j'en profite pour vous
dire que j'aurais grand plaisir à
continuer de travailler avec vous sur
ces sujets
comment l'État peut-il aider plus nos
entreprises s'agit-il encore pour les
aider à pivoter d'inventer de nouvelles
aides pour ma part après le temps
nécessaire à ce qu'à l'époque nous
appelions un carnet d'étonnement j'ai pu
observer compter avec précision les
dizaines d'aides à la transition
environnementale les dizaines d'aides
largement financés pour par l'État au
service du diagnostic environnemental
dans nos entreprises
et là lorsqu'on voit le nombre d'aide
sur étagères comme on dit souvent on se
dit qu'on a en réalité le même problème
à l'endroit de nos TPME que nous le
rencontrons à l'endroit des ménages les
plus fragiles nous avons un gros
problème de non recours aux aides il y a
des aides elles sont financées elles
existent nous avons des opérateurs
calibrés qualifiés formés remarquable je
pense à l'ADEME je pense à la BPI qui
aujourd'hui dispose de ces outils je
vous épargnerai la liste longue mais je
la tiens à votre disposition de tous les
diagnostics existants je vous dirais sur
le ton de la boutade même si c'est une
demi-boutarde que nous en découvrons
encore avec mon cabinet de nouvelles
j'en ai partagé une il y a peu de temps
avec vous Madame la Présidente ces aides
elles existent
on a un sujet c'est que les entreprises
ne les connaissent pas
on a un combat amener c'est celui du non
recours de nos TPME sur ces aides à la
transition environnementale
et s'il paraît plus difficile
donc enclencher la subvention à la
source comme on a pu faire le
prélèvement à la source et bientôt la
solidarité à la source pour les ménages
je veux rappeler avec force que ces
aides existent qu'elle fonctionne je
pense le diagnostic est au flux sur le
dit je pense auprès enfin auprès vert
parce que le cas échéant on pense au
poète sur l'investissement qui est
dispensé par la BPI je pense aussi au
VTE vert qui ont été enclenchés lors du
plan de relance sur l'emploi les
dispositifs sont là leur efficacité est
démontrée mais la connaissance des
dispositifs est bien trop faible ma
priorité elle va donc être assez
pragmatique et aussi dans le souci de la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques à
laquelle j'accorde pour ma part une très
grande importance non
je n'ai pas demandé suggérer de créer de
nouvelles aides pour cette transition je
suggère qu'on accélère la connaissance
des aides le diagnostic pour toutes les
entreprises qui veulent se développer
on a aujourd'hui des chefs d'entreprise
dans les TPE dans les PME qui sont
parfaitement conscients du sens de
l'histoire qui ne veulent pas que la
transition environnementale ne soit
réservée qu'aux grandes et qui ne savent
pas toujours malgré leur volonté par
quel bout commencer
c'est le rôle des artisans c'est le rôle
des spécialistes des bureaux d'études de
les orienter c'est le rôle de l'État de
les accompagner
cette question diagnostic elle est au
cœur de la planification écologique
voulue par la première Mini je souhaite
que on accompagne beaucoup mieux la
marge des entreprises vers cette
indispensable étape du diagnostic bien
entendu je vais y associer les
opérateurs publics BPI France la dame
les chambres consulaires mais je
souhaite aussi m'appuyer sur les
fédérations professionnelles qui sont un
relais indispensable autant le
diagnostic peut être partagé
par tous les secteurs pas toutes les
filières autant les feuilles de route
dépendent considérablement des filières
des savoir-faire de chacun de nos
secteurs économiques et puisque ces
secteurs relèvent directement de mon
portefeuille le tourisme et le commerce
seront naturellement concernés c'était
d'ailleurs un des constats forts qui a
émergé des Assises du commerce dont je
présenterai les conclusions dans les
toutes prochaines semaines entre
évolution des pratiques de consommation
équité territoriales défi
environnemental le commerce concentre
certains des enjeux les plus importants
pour nos concitoyens pour ce qui
concerne le tourisme nous sommes dans
une problématique similaire qui se
retrouve d'ailleurs au cœur du plan
destination France pour lequel près de 2
milliards d'euros ont été mobilisés par
mon prédécesseur Jean-Baptiste Lemoine
et déclenché par le gouvernement
précédent nous voulons plus de tourisme
mais nous en voulant mieux forte de son
extraordinaire patrimoine naturel et
culturel la France peut bien sûr
orgueillir de son offre touristique
l'une des premières au monde mais elle
doit aussi savoir se renouveler pour
faire face notamment au défi climatiques
vous l'aurez compris mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs au-delà des défis
immédiats dont nous allons parler ce
soir je mets la transition écologique au
cœur de la feuille de route qui la
mienne mais si la transition écologique
est une urgence je devine que vous avez
en tête d'autres urgences en plus de
celle là et j'aurais plaisir bien
entendu dès maintenant à répondre à
toutes vos questions je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la miss pour ces
propos liminaires qui du coup appelle
beaucoup de questions j'ai beaucoup
d'inscrits donc comme d'habitude je vais
vous demander voilà de ne pas être
répétitif sur les questions qui auraient
déjà été posées si possible je vais
laisser la parole à Laurence saumon et
ensuite à Martine Berthet
présidente trois questions très courtes
pour ce que effectivement elles vont
être nombreuses je voulais vous évoquer
la problème de l'endive riz dans le
département de la Somme pour lequel les
négociations avec les distributeurs
d'électricité sont extrêmement
compliquées puisque s'il n'en est pas
distribué par le distributeur
traditionnel de DF et bien les coûts
sont multipliés par 4 c'est à dire qu'on
demande pour la renouvellement des
contrats les endiguiers sont tenus soit
de ne plus
s'approvisionner soit de passer de 200
000 à 800.000 euros le coût de leur
contrat énergétique donc quelle est la
mesure que le gouvernement entend
prendre pour permettre à EDF de
renégocier gérer des tarifs qui soient
raisonnables puisque pour les autres
clients il propose des tarifs à 300000
euros voilà un exemple concret de la de
l'impact de l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie le deuxième question c'est par
rapport justement aux étés aux ETI PMI
notamment pour les usines
électrochimiques dans le cadre des
délestages qui sont prévus
on dit on parle de coupure de deux
heures tournantes pour l'électricité or
les ces usines électrochimiques ont
besoin d'avoir de la visibilité sur la
durée puisque pour
en l'occurrence SFG société française de
galvanou plastique il faut 5 heures pour
arrêter 5h pour redémarrer avant de
pouvoir refaire des mains électriques
donc quelle mesure se reprise pour ces
entreprises particulières et troisième
question par rapport aux aides
effectivement que le gouvernement met en
place est-ce que vous allez simplifier
jusqu'au dire effectivement des
industriels ou des entrepreneurs le la
demande de subvention en ligne et
extrêmement compliquée et a dû être
pendu par un énarque
ça c'est ça c'est gratuit alors Martine
Bertin ensuite Christian Redon sarrazzi
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je suis co-rapporteur de la
délégation entreprises sur la mission
relative à la RSE donc je souhaitais
relayer l'inquiétude des entreprises
mais vous avez devancé ma question tout
de même je voudrais insister sur cette
grande inquiétude de nos TPE PME car
effectivement comme vous le disiez si
elles ne sont pas directement concernées
par la directive CSRD elles le sont de
toute façon en tant que sous-traitante
et il y a un coût important pour elle
qu'elles anticipent déjà aussi bien sur
les moyens en personnel à consacrer à
cette directive en tout cas à ses
obligations pour elle en conséquence
mais aussi sur les questions d'affichage
social et du coût que cela va entraîner
pour elle non pas les moyens d'aller de
l'avant donc vous nous dites anticiper
avec beaucoup de précisions ce point
cette inquiétude alors comment
pensez-vous procéder quelles
anticipation par ailleurs également je
souhaite me faire le relais de cettepeme
sur la question des marchés publics
puisque elle n'en bénéficient souvent
dans nos territoires que comme
sous-traitante et pas en premier en
premier lieu donc comment faire pour
compter vous mettre en oeuvre des
mesures pour que nos entreprises
puissent être plus mises en avant dans
nos marchés et pas seulement que comme
sous-traitante alors je sais que voilà
c'est un petit peu délicat mais en tout
cas il faudrait que nos collectivités
territoriales puissent davantage
favoriser elles ne peuvent pas pour le
moment les entreprises locales qui font
ces efforts déjà de RSE
et puis j'aimerais également vous
alerter sur un sujet parce que
oui c'est vrai mais bon en tout cas il y
a un sujet
sur j'aimerais vous alerter également
sur les PGE et les possibilités
effectivement de prolonger CPGE de les
différer pour nos entreprises sauf que
inévitablement cela entraîne pour elle
des dégradations de leur notation Banque
de France et c'est un réel sujet donc là
aussi je ne sais pas si voilà quels sont
les moyens pour vous d'intervenir sur ce
sujet là et enfin vous dire que sur le
sujet du coût de l'énergie pour nos
entreprises malheureusement beaucoup ne
enfin pas à travers les mailles du filet
je pense à une entreprise voilà merci
merci aller plus loin mais en tout cas
ce n'est pas suffisant voilà vu le
nombre de questions je suis obligé un
petit peu de réduire Christian Redon au
Sarrasi ensuite Bernard buis oui merci
le président madame la ministre
que je souhaiterais vous interroger sur
un dispositif qui est très prisé dans
les zones rurales la notion de ZRR on le
sait le dispositif actuel étant sursis
même s'il a été prolongé jusqu'à la fin
2023 un rapport a été remis au printemps
dernier qui faisait qui faisait tard le
salon de proposition j'en citerai
quelques unes le double zonage est
derrière classique ZRR plus qui
bénéficierait notamment avec des aides
supplémentaires à l'investissement à de
nombreuses entreprises un retour au
zonage au niveau communal avec des
critères simples densité de population
revenus médian par habitant
le maintien à minima des aides en faveur
des communes notamment à la fraction
boursante de la DSR et la majoration de
la DGF et l'exonération totale de charge
pas trop mal pour les services à
domicile en particulier ainsi qu'une
détection du carburant donc dans quelle
mesure la stratégie gouvernementale en
faveur de la ruralité compte s'inspirer
de ses précon
vous pour stimuler l'emploi des jeunes
en ZRR et favoriser notamment par
exemple l'habitat rural pour les
nouveaux arrivants
merci Christian Bernard but ensuite
Franck Menonville merci présidente
madame la ministre ma question porte sur
l'éclairage nocturne des enseignes
commerciales si le cadre juridique
existe il n'est pas toujours respecté de
nombreux commerçants s'y mettent je
pense notamment chez moi dans le centre
ville de Valence et c'est tant mieux
mais ce n'est pas encore généralisé
hélas quelques heures avant la
présentation du plan de sobriété dans
une période de citoyen sont appelés à
multiplier les gestes de réduction de
consommation d'énergie quelle solution
pouvons-nous envisager pour faire
respecter les horaires d'éclairage en
période nocturne ne devrait-on pas
réduire encore la durée d'extinction
actuellement prévue entre une heure et
6h et je prolonge éventuellement cette
question vis-à-vis des collectivités
territoriales en ce qui concerne
l'éclairage public
mais ça sûrement pas
Franck Menonville ensuite Fabien gay
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre j'ai deux
questions rapides la première c'est de
faire l'écho de donc
de la vedette très forte préoccupations
dans nos territoires ruraux en matière
de commerce et notamment dans le domaine
de la boulangerie les boulangers après
avoir subi de nombreuses hausses de
matières premières aujourd'hui subissent
les coudes de l'énergie alors il y a des
situations très variables d'une d'une
situation à une autre mais force cette
constater que un secteur qui est déjà et
notamment dans en zone rurale avec le
mécanisme de tournée de de déplacement
etc
fragile c'était des secteur déjà
fragilisés aujourd'hui on sent vraiment
de très grandes difficultés à paraître
la deuxième la deuxième question c'est
aussi une inquiétude dans le réseau des
champs de consulaires qui a été évoqué
par notre collègue le président bavary
et plus particulièrement dans le domaine
des champs de consulaires d'essai
effectivement elle se sont régionalisées
et je crois que dans le budget qui est
en préparation il y a de nouveau des
coupes budgétaires qui sont qui sont
prévus de l'ordre de 15 millions d'euros
alors même que il faut le dire le
secteur dont elles ont la compétence
nécessite une vraie présence
territoriale voilà
finir cette première salle de question
par Fabien gay
merci Madame la Président Monsieur
président madame la ministre
PME en font face à une tripe difficulté
difficulté d'approvisionnement certains
nombre de matières premières difficultés
de main d'oeuvre
certains nombre de secteurs et la
difficulté énergétique je suis d'accord
avec vous Madame la Ministre il y a des
effets conjoncturels que tout le monde
connaît des effets structurels je pense
qu'on aura le débat la semaine prochaine
en séance je pense que la question du
marché européenne l'énergie ne
fonctionne plus donc il va falloir voir
ça moi je pense que une des questions
qui nous est posée là c'est de se dire
que pour l'ensemble de nos entreprises
et je mets aussi nos collectivités même
si je sais que c'est pas votre
portefeuille la question du retour au
tarif réglementé au moins sur deux ou
trois ans nous est posé je sais que
c'était Oni ici et y compris par un
certain nombre d'entre eux d'entre vous
et y compris composé ça la question on
nourrit un peu nez je pense que le ras
avoir le débat sur permettre l'accès au
tarifs réglementé à tout le monde
de passer la crise elle est posée
première chose la deuxième chose je vais
très vite sur une question que vous a
posé madame la Présidente sur les
effectifs de la DGCCRF je pense que nous
avons une question un certain nombre de
rapports de nos collègues on en a fait
un nous sur les missions d'information
mais j'ai envie de dire depuis 5 ans que
je suis ici à chaque fois sur un certain
nombre de rapports ont pointe la
question des effectifs qui permettent à
la DGCCRF de remplir leur mission dans
des bonnes conditions madame la
Présidente la redit 145 personnes sur le
droit à l'information sur la question
c'est évidemment dérisoire et quand on
les a auditionnés ils nous ont dit
qu'ils n'étaient pas assez pour faire
leur mission donc est-ce que contre
rebours de tout ce qui est fait depuis
10 ans de dégraisser la DGCCRF est-ce
qu'on va remettre des moyens humains et
dernière chose juste ça c'est pour un
petit laboutade je suis très heureux
qu'on se rende compte qu'il y a le non
recours aux aides pour les entreprises
c'est vrai c'est une vraie difficulté je
pense que dans le débat public souvent
le non recours aux aides sociales aussi
est une véritable question donc si on se
pose la question pour les entreprises je
pense qu'il faut se le poser aussi pour
les citoyens les citoyens je vous
remercie très bien je vais te laisser
madame la ministre
de questions passionnantes merci madame
la Présidente
alors
je démarre par Monsieur saumon
trois questions
sur la première
j'aurais ce type de réponse quand je
sais que c'est fréquent ici dans cette
chambre vous remontez des exemples très
concrets issus des circo
moi je suis très pragmatique donc je
prends les sujets on va investiguer et
ensuite on vous apporte une réponse
personnalisée sur l'entreprise dont vous
me parlez dont la dépense est passée de
200 000 à 800.000 euros
pardon voilà donc risque de passer je
fais de mon mieux pour tout retenir j'y
mets toute mon attention mais je ne suis
pas une Arte non plus
ni politique vous êtes mal tombé vous
avez pas de bol ça vous renseigne je
n'ai fait que salarié et monter une
petite boîte alors je suggère de prendre
la tâche très précise
ça me donne l'occasion peut-être de
revenir quelques instants sur les aides
vous avez été plusieurs à les citer et
je prends
l'intégralité des critiques sur ces
aides notamment sur la possible
complexité mais j'ai à coeur aussi de
rappeler qu'elles ont été simplifiées
que le décret est paru ce week-end et je
pense que vous êtes dans un cas ici
possiblement la dépense représente une
part équivalente à 3% du chiffre
d'affaires de l'entreprise il me semble
mais je souhaiterais vérifier que le
premier exemple que vous venez de
mentionner rentre dans les grilles de la
première première étape d'aide jusqu'à 2
millions d'euros quand les dépenses
énergétiques représentent 3% du CA que
la période de référence démontre un
doublement en 22 par rapport à 21 et que
on a une baisse de be et non pas de 30%
de be alors vous pouvez rentrer je pense
que l'exemple dont vous parlez est un
exemple qui peut être concerné j'aurais
à cœur de le vérifier très concrètement
avec mes collaborateurs à la fin de
cette audition si vous l'acceptez
monsieur le sénateur sur
l'électrochimique c'est pareil c'est pas
mon genre j'adore le rugby mais en
général je fais pas de chistera mais ça
c'est pas moi c'est mon collègue Lescure
l'électrochimique on a il y a assez de
sujets de préoccupation et je pense que
cette audition va permettre d'enlever
beaucoup pour qu'on se partage les
réjouissances et donc je n'ai
oserais-je dire que les PME le commerce
l'artisanat le tourisme et professions
indépendante libérales et la conso mais
l'industrie est plutôt chez Roland
Lescure et j'aurais là aussi à coeur si
vous avez un élément un peu plus précis
à l'aune de la situation dans votre
circonscription
de le passer à mon collègue de bureau à
Bercy l'industrie et les questions
industrielles ça n'est pas que je les
rejette c'est que j'ai déjà forte à
faire et il y a un ministre à part
entière qui s'en occupe sur simplifier
les aides
vous l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur oui
on a commencé à aller simplifier oui mon
avis à moi de ministre des PME c'est
qu'il nous faut encore les simplifier je
pense que le formulaire qui a été
mentionné notamment par le sénateur gay
et plutôt un peu plus simple aujourd'hui
qu'il ne l'était en juillet 22 est-ce
qu'on a encore des marges de progression
oui et je me bats sur plusieurs sujets
ça me permet de vous dire ce sur quoi je
me bats pour nos PME au niveau de
l'énergie je vais quand même rappeler le
qu'on a plafonné
le plafonnement pardon de la hausse du
tarif réglementé de vente à 4% en 2022
pour 1,5 millions de TPE éligibles qui
bénéficie du même bouclier tarifaire au
moment où on se parle que les ménages et
donc ce TRV sera capé à 15% en janvier
2023 je veux aussi rappeler
l'augmentation du volume d'arène
je veux aussi rappeler la mise en place
des nouveaux pg-ukraine jusqu'à 15% du
chiffre d'affaires de l'entreprise pour
les entreprises qui sont directement
confrontées à la hausse des intrants je
viens de vous rappeler l'aide en
subventions pour payer les factures
d'électricité et de gaz d'entreprise qui
dépensent en gros plus de 3% de leur ca
je veux aussi vous dire qu'on a demandé
la Commission européenne de revoir
et c'est pas on a demandé comme ça en
écrivant un courrier c'est je
pose la question tous les jours et je
vous dirais que j'ai du sang breton
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle mais j'ai
une grand-mère du Finistère Nord et je
suis têtu comme une bourrique comme elle
le disait et je peux vous dire que je me
bats aux côtés de Bruno Le Maire chaque
jour pour pour élargir assouplir
premièrement l'entrée dans les aides et
notamment le niveau de CA requis du
pourcentage de ca pour rentrer dans le
dispositif après vous connaissez le
la méthode comme moi il faut mener de
multiples combats pour parvenir à en
gagner 1 donc si je ne parviens pas à
réussir avec Bruno Le Maire a assouplir
le dispositif d'aide au niveau européen
sachez qu'on se bat aussi sur l'idée
d'une extension ou d'un accompagnement
plus large de type TRV qui pourrait
aller jusqu'à nos PME on se balade
dessus je vous l'ai dit et je vous le
redis on voit l'ensemble des
fournisseurs d'énergie demain matin à
Bercy avec Agnès avec Bruno Le Maire
avec Roland Lescure ce sera aussi
l'occasion de leur poser des questions
de mon côté et c'est aussi l'importance
de ces auditions de vous le dire en
amont des questions très pragmatiques
qui pourraient consister aussi à donner
un peu de souffle à nos TPE à nos PME en
matière de délai de paiement sur des
factures qui sont extrêmement élevées on
a quand même une conjonction c'est pour
ça que je parlais de conjoncture dans
mon propos liminaire on a une
conjonction de préoccupation et de
créances dans nos TPME qui arrive un peu
comme un goulet d'étranglement enfin
d'année vous avez mentionné les PGE je
vais y revenir il y a ces factures
d'énergie je voudrais pas qu'on oublie
façon de les réussi les hausse de
salaire que de nombreuses PME ont alloué
à leurs salariés depuis la rentrée de
septembre et nos PME ne sont pas en
reste tout ça réduit vous le savez comme
moi les marges et donc ne serait-ce que
de bénéficier d'un peu d'échéancier de
paiement voire de se donner peut-être le
temps de discuter dans le cadre de cet
échéance pour voir si on pourrait
obtenir un geste des énergéticiens je
continue à me battre aussi sur ce
terrain là je veux aussi terminer en
vous disant que l'accord de vendredi
dernier au niveau européen est un accord
assez important sur une proposition de
règlement cet accord prévoit d'abord un
objectif de réduction de la conso de 10%
ça on le fait déjà dans notre pays ils
prévoient aussi le plafonner les
recettes des producteurs d'électricité
et de mettre en place vous le savez un
prélèvement de solidarité sur les
producteurs d'énergie fossiles qui
pourraient parvenir à récupérer à peu
près 140 milliards d'euros et le Conseil
a également prévu je vais être précise
avec vous
que on poursuivrait la discussion lors
de la réunion des chefs de l'Union
européenne à Prague si c'est 7 octobre
prochain où nous continuerons d'aborder
les premiers métiers liés au prix de
l'énergie au découplage gaz électricité
et à la possibilité je l'espère
peut-être d'accéder à un dispositif de
protection type TRV d'inspiration TRV
plus large en périmètre qui pourrait
concerner nos PME donc on a encore
certes beaucoup de boulot mais beaucoup
d'énergie pour combattre ses factures
qui qui montent et vous dire qu'on est
chaque jour sur le sujet et chaque jour
je suis saisi et d'ailleurs je suis là
pour ça je vous rassure par des TPU et
des PME que je me permets aussi dans le
cadre de la reconduction de leur contrat
de transférer directement au Médiateur
de l'énergie ça n'est pas un appel à
m'envoyer forcément toutes les TPME de
vos circonscriptions qui renégocient
leur contrat mais je suis aussi là pour
ça le Médiateur de l'énergie est saisi
Bruno Le Maire a été très clair je vais
les tout autant nous attendons des prix
raisonnables et raisonnés avec des
offres nous voulons une offre au moins
pour chaque entreprise et le Médiateur
de l'énergie a été saisi par roll en
Lescure nous faisons chaque jour
remonter des dossiers notre
détermination elle est absolue elle est
tout aussi absolue que les difficultés
s'amoncellent pour nos TPME
pardonnez-moi la relativement longueur
de cette explication sur l'énergie mais
ça me semble très important ça va me
permettre d'enchaîner madame Berthet sur
CSRD je vais vous dire
ça me perdra peut-être mais on ne se
refait pas je suis moi-même disait Oscar
Wilde parce que tous les autres sont
déjà pris et ben moi je vais être
moi-même je crois qu'il faut pas que nos
PME subissent c'est SRD je pense que ça
peut paraître compliqué mais je pense
que c'est une formidable opportunité je
pense que c'est un enjeu majeur de
compétitivité de nos PME et je pense que
c'est un enjeu majeur d'attractivité de
nos PME on a parlé pénurie de main
d'oeuvre on en reparlera ça fait
aujourd'hui partie des des tops
problèmes dans nos PME la difficulté à
recruter des collaborateurs nos PME
arriveront pas à recruter si elle ne
considère pas le moment dans lequel nous
sommes et la transition environnementale
et sociale que les consommateurs mais
aussi les salariés et la génération qui
arrive sur le marché du travail appelle
de leur vœu on assiste à une mutation
majeure je vais pas faire un exposé mais
vous le vivez comme moi et ne pas
accompagner nos PME dans ces mutations
seraient irresponsable je pèse mes mots
bien sûr en matière de compétitivité je
vais revenir sur CSRD mais aussi en
matière d'attractivité elle ne
parviendront pas à tirer des talons si
on a on n'arrive pas à les accompagner
dans cette dynamique CSRD ça a été voté
après des années de négociation et je
crois que il y a un moment où c'est
aussi l'heure de vérité CSRD ça n'est
pas une directive en réalité même si
elle porte le doux nom de la performance
extra-financière CSRD ça n'est rien de
moins que le dessin du capitalisme
européen que nous voulons promouvoir et
le D et le dessin de ce que nous ne
voulons pas pouvoir en matière de
pratique capitalistique environnementale
sociale et de gouvernance en Europe et
donc c'est vrai que CSRD est une
directive extrêmement importante et
l'enjeu ça n'est plutôt les grands
groupes puisque vous le savez comme moi
madame la sénatrice elle sont déjà
astreintes à ce qu'on appelle la dpef la
déclaration de performance
extra-financière et donc les grands
groupes depuis 2014 sont à culturer à
coutumer à ces déclarations donc ils ont
les équipes ils ont le savoir-faire ils
ont même un peu l'expérience l'enjeu
majeur aujourd'hui c'est que ces SRD ne
crée pas non plus une rupture entre les
grandes entreprises et les petites et
vous l'avez dit nombre d'entre elles
seront concernés indirectement par le
truchement de la sous-traitance je ne
prends pas ça comme une mauvaise
nouvelle les PME ne sont pas directement
concernés dans le champ de la directive
mais comme j'assume mes actes je me suis
battu pour que les PME qui le souhaitent
puissent aussi volontairement enclencher
la performance extra-financière le cas
échéant elle le subiront et le cas
échéant elle perdront et compétitivité
et attractivité maintenant la question
c'est comment on les accompagne comment
on fait en sorte que elle puisse
enclencher leur bilan carbone de Scop 1
de scope de voir leur bilan social c'est
tout l'enjeu des aides qui sont financés
par l'État c'est tout l'enjeu qui est le
mien aujourd'hui du fameux dernier
kilomètre de faire en sorte que nos PME
sachent que l'État finance pour partie
des dispositifs de diagnostics qui
doivent leur permettre non pas de subir
mais de profiter de ce qui va se passer
avec l'extra financier je pense que
c'est très important je pense même que
nombre de patrons de PME sont désireux
de prendre ce virage tout à la fois bien
sûr pour leurs équipes leur attractivité
mais aussi leurs compétitivité et c'est
pourquoi on a lancé il y a maintenant
deux ans cette plateforme dont j'avais
pris le temps de venir vous parler
lorsque j'étais à l'économie sociale et
resp
et vous voyez madame Berthet c'est
intéressant de voir que là aussi on
m'avait dit comme pendant la loi Pâques
sur les sociétés à mission et la raison
d'être que c'était un truc de grandes
corporate et que ça n'intéresserait pas
les PME et bien la plus grande partie
des sociétés à mission dans notre pays
sont des PME nombre de PME sont inscrits
sur un pack.gouv.fr parfois plus même
que certains grands groupes ont étéi
industriels et les PME je crois qu'elles
veulent être partie prenante de cette
évolution donc je j'entends votre
préoccupation moi je pense que ce qu'il
faut c'est non pas le subir mais les
accompagner les accompagner notamment en
finançant pour partie des diagnostics
environnementaux voir sociaux je suis
ouverte à toute discussion dans les
années qui viennent pour qu'elles ne les
subissent pas mais qu'elle soit partie
prenante de la Révolution
extra-financière sur les marchés publics
je vais vite
sinon mais moi c'est un plaisir mais je
risque de rester jusqu'à 23h avec vous
mais après on est sujet
mais comme j'ai fait la sortie sur
l'énergie j'espère que j'y reviendrai
pas doucement mais après ce sont des
sujets majeurs les marchés publics je
rappelle que dans climat est résilience
on a eu l'occasion d'en reparler et
j'étais à l'époque au banc on a un
nouveau plan national d'achat durable le
PNA a aidé qui est consultable qui est
d'ailleurs ouvert là c'est pareil je moi
je suis pas
décentralisatrice les années bissextiles
je suis décentralisatrices tous les ans
et même tous les mois et je pense que
c'est au collectivité locale de faire
leurs appels d'offres à l'état peut-être
de donner les outils c'est ce que l'État
fait d'ailleurs avec le le pnad qui
permet aux acheteurs publics de bâtir
leur marché public mais je ne crois pas
que ce soit à l'état d'écrire les
marchés publics en l'occurrence dans les
collectivités locales on a fait des
avancées avec la qui m'a résilience et
après il y a certaines collectivités
locales qui sont taxées exemplaires et
inspirantes en matière
d'insertion soit d'entreprises
d'insertion soit d'ailleurs de TPE et de
PME c'est à l'achat et je dirais en
fonction aussi de la sensibilité des
collectivités locales et je pense que
c'est bien comme ça même si l'état
pousse au maximum pour faire bouger les
pratiques sur les PGE sur les PGE qui
est un sujet majeur d'abord j'ai à cœur
de vous rappeler que la Banque de France
au moment où on se parle à estimer le
taux de défaut à 4,6%
le taux de défaut prévisionnel sur la
durée de vie du dispositif ça n'est pas
rien j'en suis consciente ça n'est pas
non plus un risque systémique au moment
où je vous parle
pour autant 4,6% c'est quand même des
femmes des hommes des entrepreneurs
derrière et donc je suis bien conscient
des difficultés qui peuvent rencontrer
vous le savez on a mobilisé
deux types d'acteurs la médiation du
crédit j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer
à leur endroit par le traitement de la
Banque de France il y a des antennes de
la Banque de France dans chaque
département il y a donc possibilité de
saisir la médiation du crédit pour
réchonner son PG sur 10 ans on le fait
tous les jours
il y a aussi possibilité c'est important
de solliciter le conseiller
départemental à la sortie de crise il y
en a un dans chaque département et je
suis à votre entière disposition leurs
coordonnées sont en ligne et donc
publiques réuni la semaine dernière à
Bercy tous les jours il réel des PGE et
tous les jours
aussi des dettes sociales d'être
fiscales pour permettre à nos
entrepreneurs de payer leur PGE non la
cotation madame la sénatrice n'est pas
automatique non et 4 fois non même 5
fois non je rappelle que la cotation
FIBEN ne tombe en l'occurrence et j'y
reviendrai que pour les entreprises dans
le chiffre d'affaires est supérieur à
750 000 euros c'est loin d'être le cas
de toutes nos TPE et de nos PME il y a
pas de cotation FIBEN à moins de 750 000
euros de chiffre d'affaires moi je veux
bien qu'on ait peur je veux qu'on ait
peur des vraies choses là on a peur d'un
fantasme je le redis il n'y a pas de
cotation FIBEN à moins de 754 de chiffre
d'affaires
deuxièmement la cotation pour les
entreprises et c'est pour ça c'est super
important ce que je partage avec vous
parce que pour avoir été plus longtemps
député que ministre je sais l'importance
aussi de la voix des élus locaux quand
ils reviennent dans leur territoire je
moins de 750 000 euros pas de cotation
FIBEN plus il peut y avoir une note dite
non performante j'ai à cœur de rappeler
premièrement qu'elle n'était rien
automatique elle est réalisée au cas par
cas ça n'est pas parce qu'une entreprise
réel automatiquement elle est classée en
non performante deuxièmement j'ai aussi
à coeur de rappeler que cette note elle
est absolument discrétionnaire que seul
le banquier le connaît qu'évidemment que
les assureurs crédit ne le connaissent
pas ça me semble important aussi à
rappeler et en l'occurrence j'ai aussi à
cœur de vous rappeler on a des exemples
tous les jours à Bercy que les capacités
d'emprunt malgré une notation non
performante ne sont pas automatiquement
bloqué on a des entreprises qui ont été
classées pour d'autres raisons bien
avant le PGE en non performante et qui
réussissent à investir et à obtenir des
investissements donc je suis à votre
disposition sur des sujets des PG très
précis voir sur une saisine de la
médiation mais sur la notation j'ai à
cœur de dire vraiment qu'elle est pas
automatique et en l'occurrence pas pour
noter PME
sur la question ZRR je vais vous
décevoir
et je m'en excuse
oui mais je
me suis pardon je vous cherchez monsieur
Redon alors je suis désolé monsieur
Redon ça rasi votre question elle est
très très large et malgré ma tentative
pour le coup j'ai rien chez moi ZRR je
vous recommande et je suis plus qu'à
disposition côté fiscal il faut voir ça
avec le cabinet de Monsieur Attal on a
Dominique fort qui est aussi secrétaire
des chats en détente en charge des
questions à la ruralité et sur la partie
territoriale pour avoir vice-présidé la
commission des finances au Parlement je
connais l'importance des adrr pour le
coup c'est Christophe BECHU qu'il faut
qu'il faut se liciter sur la partie
travail ce sera plus mon collègue du
socle mais j'ai à cœur de vous dire
Monsieur le Sénateur que sur tous ces
noms je suis à votre disposition
monsieur buis éclairage nocturne
on a une obligation légale je vais
directement dans le dur pour les agglots
de moins de 800000 habitants
d'extinction des enseignes lumineuses
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le sénateur
entre 1h et 6h du matin avec pour les
agglo de plus de 800000 habitants une
réglementation a fixée par les élus
locaux dans le règlement local de
publicité
ça peut ne pas suffire j'entends votre
interrogation et avec en espagnol on a
soumis après concertation un projet de
décret en Conseil d'État qui prévoit
d'imposer l'extinction des enseignes
lumineuses entre 1h et 6h sur l'ensemble
du territoire sanctionné par des
contraventions de 5e classe
et ça c'est pareil je peux vous dire que
mon cabinet peut attester du nombre de
fois où je leur pose la question tous
les jours
j'ai l'honneur donc de vous dire on est
mardi alors je peux vous préviens si
c'est pas le cas je perds toute
crédibilité ce décret sera publié après
le bain
croyable
après demain donc un s'il est pas publié
compter sur moi pour le rappeler
ça non non
décret aussi donc
et mon équipe peut en attester donc
voilà il va paraître pour ce qui est de
la de la sanction et des contraventions
sont les les pouvoirs de police du maire
qui permettent la contravention de 5ème
classe et quant à ce décret normalement
le 6 octobre il devrait être paru
les boulangers
alors les boulangers vrai sujet
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
un vrai sujet vrai réponse que nous nous
parlons avec la Fédération des
boulangers et que je les reçois fin du
mois je reçois leur délégation le 18
octobre prochain à Bercy on a plusieurs
types de sujets et notamment aussi le
fait qu'on a plusieurs types de
boulangerie et qu'elles n'ont pas toutes
les mêmes fours et qu'elles n'ont donc
pas toutes les mêmes consommations il y
a des très grandes boulangeries
d'ailleurs parfois même en milieu rural
ou périurbain il y a des boulangeries
beaucoup plus petites et leur
consommation sont pas du tout les mêmes
façons de vous dire qu'il y en a qui
sont parfaitement éligibles au tarif
réglementé et donc au bouclier
tarifaires et d'autres qui ne le sont
pas et donc il faut qu'on trouve des
solutions pour celles qui sont plus
exposées et qui ne sont pas je peux vous
dire Bruno Le Maire et moi-même sommes
disposés à allez-y aider pour ce qui est
du commerce rural évidemment d'abord je
voulais remercier des sénateurs et le
président babary pour les 10 axes sur le
commerce rural qui me nourrissent je
sais que vous allez vous dire ça fait
déjà trois mois que je suis là mais vu
l'ampleur du périmètre on a pris
connaissance de l'ensemble de ces
mesures 48 mesure et 10 axes donc je
peux vous dire qu'on en a certaines
qu'on va très certainement embarquer
avec nous j'aurais à cœur d'en parler
très certainement lors des la conclusion
des Assises du commerce
et j'ai à coeur d'encourager comme le
font certaines initiatives privées comme
1000 café mais aussi bouge ton coq ou
comptoir de campagne d'encourager
l'établissement des commerces
multiservices je pense aussi assez
intéressant mais j'aurais à cœur
peut-être qu'on en parle ensemble
d'encourager le commerce itinérant dans
certaines de nos communes rurales qui
connaît d'ailleurs un succès
notamment auprès des jeunes générations
qui reprennent un certain nombre de
commerces itinérants à voir on peut pas
ensemble trouver des dispositions pour
les porter et que je puisse agir aussi à
l'aune du rapport qui a été proposé par
les sénateurs sur les CMA
sur les CMA la taxe affectée au CMA et
plafonné à
[Musique]
200 3 millions d'euros ce plafond est
resté stable depuis 2016 dans le cas du
PLF 23 une baisse du plafond de cette
taxe est proposée afin que les CMA
contribué aux efforts collectifs pour la
maîtrise des finances publiques à
hauteur de 15 millions d'euros je sais
pour les recevoir très souvent que
l'augmentation des charges de personnel
dans le cadre de la négociation sur la
revalorisation du point d'indice des
personnels à lakout à laquelle ça ajoute
le coût annuel de la gypa préoccupe les
les chambres
des des métiers j'ai veillé à ce que
cette baisse de plafond en 2023 soit
soutenable les travaux j'ai aussi je
trouve ça important de partager avec
vous les travaux de préparation du
prochain Coop pour la période 23-26 vont
permettre de prioriser les missions des
CMA je suis parfaitement consciente au
nom du gouvernement de l'importance de
l'effort qui est demandé et dans le
contexte budgétaire contraint pour les
finances publiques et aussi on rappelle
des efforts faites par les autres
chambres conçu elle que consulaires
pardon sont les CCI je maintiens cette
orientation budgétaire mais comme nous
sommes en démarrage de PLF je connais
l'importance des débats parlementaire et
nous verrons comment tout ça se déroule
monsieur le sénateur gay sur TPME
TRV
je vous l'ai dit je voudrais pas me
répéter ça peut être la 100
il y a ce qui existe qu'on a simplifié
il y a 1,5 millions de TPE qui
bénéficient du TRV on a un tout petit
peu plus de 3 millions de TPE donc on a
un sujet sur est-ce qu'on peut en rendre
plus éligible côté TPE on a aussi un
sujet sur quelle mesure pour les PME
vous êtes tous des élus engagés donc moi
j'ai à cœur aussi dans le cadre de ces
auditions enfin je suis pas au plateau
télé là donc j'ai à cœur de partager
avec vous des choses que je ne dis pas
forcément
je sais bien mais je partage avec vous
au-delà du TRV on a aussi des
des idées parce qu'il faut avoir
plusieurs faire au feu vous le savez
monsieur le sénateur gay et donc on
réfléchit aussi la première ministre la
mentionner très rapidement aux questions
d'actualité juste avant que je vous
rejoigne à l'Assemblée nationale on
travaille aussi en parallèle d'un
possible TRV PME que pour ma part
j'appelle de mes vœux un filet de
sécurité qui permettrait de de rendre
moins douloureux l'augmentation des prix
de l'énergie si ceux-ci continuait à
monter donc je veux juste vous dire
qu'on a plusieurs phares au feu je vais
vous dire que ma préoccupation elle est
absolue sur ce sujet et que la prise en
charge par Bruno Le Maire elle est
quotidienne donc au quotidien j'inclus
les nuits
je pense qu'on va parvenir à trouver une
solution et je pense que l'Europe pourra
nous parvenir je l'espère à en trouver
une je vise vendredi le prochain conseil
à Prague et le cas échéant je rappelle
les conseils des 11 et 12 octobre il y
en a toutes les semaines je peux vous
dire que la détermination du
gouvernement français et totale sur ce
sujet sur la DGCCRF
pardonnez-moi le je vous remercie les
enfin le sénateur Cosic et la sénatrice
espagnole pour le rapport
je veux aussi dire que la DG CCRF a fait
des efforts incommensurables ces
dernières années que je connais bien le
sujet pour avoir eu l'honneur d'être
rapporteur en commission des finances et
vous dire que j'échange plusieurs fois
par mois avec la directrice Madame
baumenier avec mon cabinet est en
contact hebdomadaire avec la DGCCRF j'ai
à cœur d'échanger avec elle sur vos
recommandations dans un contexte et je
tiens à le souligner qui est par
ailleurs marqué par un redéploiement des
effectifs de la DGCCRF vers des missions
prioritaires en matière de transition
écologique et numérique notamment vers
le ministère de l'Agriculture qui est
plus plus à même sur un certain nombre
de contrôles d'agir je veux aussi vous
dire j'aurais l'occasion de les payer
plus dans quelques mois mais qu'une
augmentation des emplois de la DGCCRF
est prévu en 2023 et en 2024 et les
transferts d'emploi de la dgccr a vers
le ministère de l'Agriculture que je
viens de vous mentionner pour l'émission
relatives à la sécurité sanitaire sont
limités pour lui permettre justement de
réorienter son action vers ces nouvelles
priorités encore une fois j'aurais à
cœur peut-être à la fin d'année ou au
pire en début d'année prochaine a étayer
le fait que cette baisse d'effectif est
terminée et qu'il est même question de
redéployer un certain nombre de TP vu
l'importance stratégique des missions de
la DGCCRF dans le contexte de
consommation qu'il neutre sujet auquel
je suis très sensible pardonnez-moi
madame la Présidente j'ai essayé d'être
aussi exhaustive que possible merci
Madame amnis nous allons passer et on va
prendre toutes les questions d'un coup
donc je vous demanderai d'être rapide et
peut-être madame la ministre plus
condensé sur vos réponses parce que
voilà on voit beaucoup de plaisir à
échanger avec vous mais il faut être
raisonnable Olivier Rickman et ensuite
Daniel
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je suis Cora porteur d'une
mission de suivi de la délégation aux
entreprises sur le thème de la
transmission d'entreprise notre rapport
sera examiné jeudi matin et je dois dire
qu'il y a un sujet qui dépense certes
plus directement du ministre du Travail
mais qui a un impact direct sur nos PME
TPE ainsi que ti ce qui doit vous
intéresser directement c'est la question
de la formation je pense par exemple à
la formation des futurs repreneurs
d'entreprise dont on manque cruellement
aujourd'hui en France
or la Caisse des Dépôts récemment des
référencé CR1 formation qui dépend de
l'association Sedan et repreneur
d'affaires alors que ces formations font
l'unanimité de tous les acteurs de la
transmission qu'ils soient publics ou
privés
la vague de déréférencement également
touché de nombreux auto-écoles qui ne
peuvent plus non plus bénéficier du
financement via CPF or dans nos
territoires ruraux c'est un vrai
handicap pour nos entreprises car sans
permis pas de voiture sans voiture les
travailleurs ne peuvent pas trouver
d'emploi et les PME et TPE font face à
une pénurie extrême de compétences je
pense par exemple au transporteur qui
avait en face deux des candidats qui
bénéficiaient du CPF pour passer leur
permis poids lourd à super lourd et qui
ne peuvent plus le faire cette question
est cruciale pour nos entreprises et
nous espérons que vous pourrez aborder
la question donc avec votre collègue
Olivier du socle car l'enjeu est de
taille et doit être appréhendée de façon
transversale pour ma part j'ai sollicité
le ministre du socle le 5 août pas de
réponse le 13 septembre toujours pas de
réponse la délégation aux entreprises à
solliciter la Caisse des Dépôts pas de
réponse donc mon petit doigt me dit que
vu l'impact qu'il peut y avoir lieu sur
les petites entreprises et les moyennes
entreprises
une réponse de votre part et je vous en
remercie
Olivier il faudrait pense que la
ministre aura de l'influence Daniel
Laurent ensuite Sylviane Noël madame
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
juste il y a beaucoup de choses qui ont
été évoquées mais vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que c'est la question de
l'énergie qui préoccupe au premier temps
pour les premiers plans actuellement les
chefs d'entreprise
il y a pas que ça parce que ça ça grège
à l'inflation qui menace les entreprises
et les ménages les difficultés de
recrutement les délais
d'approvisionnement toujours plus tendus
l'envoler des coups des matériaux les
marges qui se réduisent et
malheureusement les trésories qui pour
certains deviennent exemples
juste trois questions puisque beaucoup
de sujets ont été évoqués une les
entreprises en fin de contrat sont
incitées à repousser la négociation des
contrats d'énergie alors ça c'est le
président de la République l'a évoqué ne
signait surtout pas vos contrats or en
pratique c'est plus compliqué pour les
PME qui ne font pas le poids pour peser
sur les fournisseurs d'énergie lesquels
ne peuvent leur garantir ni les volumes
ni s'engager sur les prix la deuxième
chose la deuxième question sur le
bouclier de tarifaire pouvez-vous
préciser si toutes les activités sont
bien concernées et là je pense aux
activités agricoles transformations
distillation qui ont besoin beaucoup
d'énergie c'est pour ça que je vous pose
la question ensuite
deux autres questions supplémentaires le
dysfonctionnement je l'avais déjà posé à
votre prédécesseur le dysfonctionnement
dans le reversement collectivité de la
taxe de séjour ça concerne le tourisme
via les plateformes numériques perdure
que comptez-vous faire pour en améliorer
le fonctionnement sachant que votre
prédécesseur à qui j'ai posé la question
n'a pas résolu le problème
et le dernière question la révision du
référentiel des stations de tourisme qui
imposent la présence d'une pharmacie sur
le territoire communal des stations
classées un exemple une commune de 600
habitants dans mon territoire situé dans
l'île de Ré pourraient perdre le
classement dans le cadre d'un prochain
renouvellement comme il y a même deux
pharmacies sont à moins de 5 minutes
envisagez-vous une adaptation aux
réalités de ces territoires merci
Daniel pour ces questions précises s'ils
viennent Noël ensuite Viviane Artigalas
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
brièvement l'activité ski s'agissant des
activités impactées par la hausse des
coûts de l'énergie en associant un mes
propos ma collègue Martine Berthet c'est
en effet un sujet de préoccupation
majeur puisque aujourd'hui 70% des
stations de ski de notre pays négocient
leur contrat trianal avec les
fournisseurs d'énergie après deux
saisons gâchées par la pandémie de
covid-19 la hausse des prix pourrait à
nouveau venir menacer ce secteur
d'activité et les stations supports de
et les communes pardon supports de
station de montagne puisque
l'électricité pourrait représenter à la
fin de la saison 20% de leur coup contre
deux à cinq % actuellement si cette hôte
n'est pas contrôle et les conséquences
risque d'être très lourdes pour les
communes supports de station avec toutes
les répercussions sur le tissu
socio-économique que nous avons connu il
y a deux ans et qui a été très fort je
vous réitère donc la nécessité absolue
d'accompagner les opérateurs de remontée
mécanique pour passer ce cap difficile
et deuxième sujet la commission de
tourisme que je précise a été récemment
saisi par les représentants de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration sur les
commissions que prélève certaines
plateformes liées à la dématérialisation
des titres restaurants c'est ces
plateformes sont en situation de quasi
monopole il semblerait que ces acteurs
prélèvent des frais fixes et
emploi direct générés ou maintenus selon
les régions par le tourisme de proximité
en 2019 les vertus environnementales de
cette forme de villégiature ont été
reconnus par l'ADEME dans son rapport
sur les émissions touristiques de 2020
le rapport faisait quelques propositions
par exemple la structuration d'offre
touristique de proximité la mise en
place d'incitation fiscale pour les
acteurs du tourisme micro local le
développement de l'offre ferroviaire la
mise en place d'une campagne de
communication spécifique pour le
tourisme local madame la ministre le
gouvernement soit-il prendre des mesures
pour favoriser le tourisme de proximité
et si oui lesquels
Viviane Serge Mérillou ensuite Florence
blatrix compta alors la question a déjà
été abordée partiellement mais depuis
quelques jours l'exécutif alerte des
patrons de TPE PME afin qu'ils ne signe
pas des contrats d'électricité à des
prix exorbitants oreiller madame vargon
président de la creux s'est montré moins
catégorique en expliquant qu'en réalité
certaines entreprises avaient tout
intérêt à signer les contrats proposés
au risque de se retrouver sans
fournisseur en janvier nos entreprises
vont devoir prendre des décisions à
brève délai madame la ministre les
entreprises doivent-elles ou non signer
les contrats proposés au prix actuel
avec les risques derrière de mise en
place de chômage partiel compte tenu des
prix élevés d'électricité ces prix de
contrats donc très élevés surtout très
volatiles sont compliquées à comprendre
par des chefs d'entreprise qui n'ont pas
qui n'ont pas de de conseiller pour pour
prendre ses décisions
comment le gouvernement peut-il rendre
ses prix plus lisibles afin de guider
les entreprises dans leur choix
stratégique et pour terminer les TPE PME
ont besoin de clarté et de cohérence et
pour leur prise de décision et la
cacophonie gouvernementale ne facilite
pas à ce type de décision
merci Serge Florence blatrix-cont
incker
Florence merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre madame le ministre je
me réjouis de vos annonces concernant la
DGCCRF c'était une nécessité et les
agriculteurs le réclament pour un
meilleur contrôle de la loi et Gallim
vous dire aussi à l'approche du budget
et dans le contexte inflationniste que
nous connaissons la nécessité de
renforcer le financement des
associations de consommateurs qui ont vu
leurs aides réduites ces dernières
années c'est ça serait vraiment
indispensable cette année
nous travaillons au sein la DA sur
plusieurs sujets et notamment le la
situation des ETI et des PME en matière
de commerce extérieur elle a notre
inquiétude est grande le déficit s'est
creusé il y a des raisons
conjoncturelles je l'entends bien mais
il y a aussi des raisons vraiment
structurelles et nos PME nos ETI sont
assez peu représenter dans son assez peu
insérés dans le commerce extérieur donc
quel levier quel plan d'action
envisagez-vous pour
c'est pas moi qui t'ai coupé mais c'est
coupé
merci
vous avez entendu le et enfin sur la
question de la RSE je me réjouis de
votre enthousiasme vous dire que je le
partage et que surtout je pense qu'il
faut également une campagne
d'information de communication auprès
des entreprises et peut-être aussi
également suivre de près les normes
ephragues qui doivent être aussi
pragmatique et pertinente et porteuse de
sens voilà je vous remercie Florence
Amel gaker merci parmi les difficultés
relevées par nos entreprises donc TPE
PME et ensuite Daniel 2 sont
actuellement récurrentes celles bien sûr
relatives à l'explosion du coup
l'énergie mais également la difficulté
de recrutement
sujet déjà connu transversal car bien
sûr il ne dépend pas que de votre
ministère mais qui prend des proportions
inédites puisque 9 PME sur 10 peine à
recruter recruter pardon et ce dont tous
les secteurs face à cette pénurie nombre
de dirigeants pris le responsabilité ont
d'ores et déjà augmenté les salaires ou
verser des primes travaillent sur la
qualité de vie au travail
ma question est simple quel est votre
vision sur cette situation problématique
qui amène nombre d'entreprises
aujourd'hui à refuser des marchés
véritablement donc quel est quels
engagement pouvez-vous prendre en tout
cas pour accompagner nos entreprises sur
cette difficulté merci
merci Amel Daniel Gremillet ensuite
Daniel Salmon et on finira par Alain
Châtillon oui merci
chers collègues je vais prolonger la
question
que tu viens de poser sur les
difficultés des entreprises et des
commerçants ça fait plus d'un an que ça
dure et aujourd'hui c'est absolument
incroyable si on cumulé le chiffre
d'affaires
France perdu parce qu'on n'a pas les
serviettes en face donc je suis comme
toi il y a absolument incroyable quand
vous voyez des restaurateurs qui ferment
le soir parce qu'il y a personne pour
pouvoir servir vous prenez les
commerçants à tous niveaux il y a
vraiment un problème ma deuxième
question le temps est compté je vais pas
faire le débat d'énergie mais je ne
partage pas du tout vos propos tout à
l'heure sur la situation énergétique de
notre pays par contre ma question elle
est simple
qu'allez-vous faire pour les entreprises
dont vous avez la responsabilité par
rapport à l'Allemagne qui vient décider
de mettre 200 milliards
sur le soutien et faire en sorte que les
entreprises des commerçants ne soient
pas impactés par rapport à la crise
énergétique aujourd'hui merci Daniel
Daniel salmon
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
en tant que ministre du touriste du
tourisme je tenais à vous alerter sur la
problématique des locations courtes
durées des locations dont la
prolifération est connue par nombre
d'entre nous sur nos territoires ce
phénomène a pour conséquence de créer
une un effet d'éviction sur le marché de
la location classique pour les résidents
à l'année et cela entraîne de nombreuses
difficultés pour les employeurs on vient
d'en parler qui peinent à recruter c'est
un élément dans la difficulté à recruter
pour les commerçants les artisans les
TPE les PME
j'ai donc deux points à soulever sur ce
sujet tout d'abord la fiscalité je pense
qu'il serait souhaitable que celle
portant sur les locations courtes durées
puissent être plus strictes et plus
lourde que celle qui pèse sur le
location de longue durée également il
faudrait permettre une adoption de la
réglementation une adaptation de la
réglementation aujourd'hui
car la loi autorise seulement les
communes de plus de 200 000 habitants ou
celles situées en zone tendue à adopter
des réglementations plus strictes pour
réduire et encadrer le nombre de
locations de courte durée donc ce c'est
beaucoup trop restrictif à l'heure
actuelle donc je plaide pour que soumise
à disposition des élus une boîte à
outils afin que ces derniers puissent
adopter une réglementation en fonction
des spécificités de leur commune
et j'aurais donc souhaité et connaître
vos intentions sur ce sujet ou venez de
nous de nous dire que vous aviez des
ascendants bretonnes donc vous serez
forcément sensible à problématique que
rencontre cette région sur tout le
littoral mais pas uniquement le littoral
puisque aujourd'hui c'est même les
communes à l'intérieur des terres qui
sont touchés par cette problématique des
locations courtes durée merci
merci quand les Bretons parlent breton
deux entreprises de mon secteur de ma
région sont menacés par EDF s'il ne
signe pas d'ici une semaine un contrat
qui est
grosso modo 5 fois le prix de cette
l'année passée de l'année en cours donc
j'aimerais savoir qu'est-ce que on peut
faire dans ces cas-là je crois que c'est
un problème grave et qu'il va falloir
traiter le deuxième point vous parliez
tout à l'heure du coût productif
pour avoir participé à la demande
d'Agnès panier à deux réunions sur les
15 qu'il y a eu au à Bercy je voulais
vous dire que j'étais intervenu pour
dire que le coup productif c'était
l'impôt de production
production c'est 70 milliards en France
contre 47 milliards en Allemagne et que
pour le réduire il fallait que ce soit
l'état puisque c'est l'impôt de
production or là je vois que c'est la
CVAE c'est-à-dire les 9 milliards de la
CVAE sur deux ans donc comment se
fait-il que ce soit l'école d'activités
qui payent à la place de l'État et ça je
peux vous dire que les
intercommunalités et les communes ne
sont pas du tout d'accord
merci beaucoup madame la ministre bon
courage pardon les questions ont été
nombreuses diverses certaines reviennent
sur le propos longs que vous avez tenu
sur l'énergie donc peut-être que sur les
questions énergétiques on peut voilà
refaire quelques rappels rapides
merci madame la Présidente je vais je
suggère pour éviter d'être trop longue
je vais répondre juste à
l'amicale interpellation du sénateur
gremière
dont j'ai bien noté la première partie
de l'intervention qui est pas du tout
d'accord avec ce que j'ai dit sur
l'énergie et comme je
suis sensible à ce que vous dites
j'ai à cœur quand même de rappeler deux
trois petites pailles les Allemands ont
annoncé 200 milliards oui
peut-être avez-vous des informations
monsieur le sénateur mais moi je ne suis
absolument pas en mesure où on se parle
de voir comment ces 200 milliards vont
être ventilés pour les ménages pour les
entreprises pour le moment on se parle
on ne sait pas du tout
ce dont je suis certaine c'est que de
notre côté on a d'ores et déjà décaisser
60 milliards pour protéger nos ménages
de la hausse du prix de l'énergie
ça paraît peut-être pas suffisant mais
ça le mérite de devoir être rappelé j'ai
aussi à coeur de rappeler et je vais
répondre une par une aux questions je
vous rassure mais au sénateur Laurent
nous sommes nombreux à faire la
compilation des difficultés j'ai quand
même à coeur de rappeler que le taux
lissé août 2021 août 2022 de l'inflation
dans notre beau pays et de 5,8%
et qu'il est de 7.7% sur les produits
alimentaires oui c'est trop
mais j'ai quand même à coeur de rappeler
que nous sommes un des 27 États membres
et que cette situation est enviée dans
de nombreuses autres États et ça ne veut
pas dire pour autant que c'est pas
compliqué 5 ou 7 points d'augmentation
mais on a quand même une inflation qui
est fortement
retenu dans notre pays et autant j'ai je
reconnais mes erreurs autant je
reconnais aussi que il est important de
rappeler qu'on a été les premiers du
moins Bruno Le Maire à écrire des la
rentrée 2021 sur le sujet de la
décorrélation du prix du gaz et de
l'électricité on a aussi été les
premiers en Europe à mettre en place un
bouclier et je juste après
autant pour moi ça c'est la séparation
des pouvoirs l'exécutif a fait ce qu'il
a pu à la suite de la bonne initiative
des parlementaires mais je vous remercie
d'ailleurs de l'avoir fait mais je veux
juste dire la situation elle est
difficile pour échanger souvent avec des
homologues dans d'autres pays européens
elle est encore plus dans d'autres
endroits
sur la transmission alors sénateur
Redman
vu la charge qui est la mienne oui c'est
un sujet la transmission la formation
vous avez mentionné un CFA particulier
je suis là aussi pour transmettre
la nécessité de répondre aux questions
des sénateurs à mes collègues et amis du
gouvernement je suis étonné connaissance
Olivier duob parce que c'est pas sa
nature donc c'est une exception qui
vient confirmer sa règle et il va vous
répondre dans les meilleurs délais je
vais lui transférer la demande de
réponse à votre sollicitation je vous
recommande aussi de rencontrer peut-être
et d'en parler à Madame la Ministre
Grandjean qui est en charge de la
formation professionnelle et à votre
dispo pour vous mettre en relation
peut-être qu'elle peut vous apporter
aussi une réponse opérationnelle sur le
sujet précis que vous avez mentionné
Monsieur Laurent je reviens à votre
question
encore une fois la situation oui elle
est difficile
73% des PME au moment où on se parle
répercute la hausse des prix de
l'énergie sur leur prix de vente 73%
ça fait plusieurs mois que c'est pris
sont passés sur les prix de vente comme
je suis aussi la ministre de la
consommation j'ai à cœur que on est
aussi une approche équilibrée et que les
prix aux consommateur n'exposent pas
c'est aussi tout ce que je fais au cœur
des négociations avec Roland Lescure et
Marc fenault sur le prix Les prix
alimentaires sur la mobilisation de la
grande distribution je vais pas être
trop longue mais sachez que ça nous
préoccupe et ça nous occupe en
l'occurrence tous les jeudis puisque
dans le cadre des réunions que nous
menons à la suite des galets mégalim 2
on a toutes les semaines des échanges
sur les denrées alimentaires et sur
l'effort qui doit être partagé je me
bats moi pour que nos PME puissent
passer leur prix liés à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie ça fait plusieurs mois
qu'elle les passe
on est extrêmement vigilant pour qu'elle
puisse continuer à les passer et on a
donc appelé à la responsabilité
notamment des acteurs de la grande
distribution
en matière de pénalité de pénalité
logistique notamment donc c'est un sujet
qu'on suit de très près oui la situation
elle est compliquée
mais on va s'en sortir sur les PME que
vous mentionnez qui ont des contrats à
renégocier
je voulais dire on a saisi le médiateur
si vous avez quelques PME en main ou en
contact qui ont des problèmes concrets
de contrats à renégocier pour janvier 23
avec des tarifs qui ont triplé quadruplé
qui vous semble ou qui semble à la PME
anormaux je suis là pour prendre
rattache et transmettre aux médiateur de
l'énergie et aux équipes de Bercy donc
si vous l'acceptez peut-être qu'on
échangera nos coordonnées à la fin j'ai
à cœur d'agir de façon
éclairée sur les dossiers que vous
soulevez sur
station de tourisme enfin sur le la
classification des communes qui est un
vrai sujet vous êtes nombreux
parlementaires à l'Assemblée au Sénat
soulevé
il y a le sujet vous l'avez mentionné du
renouvellement de du classement de
commune touristique du fait de la
réforme de 2019 intégrant parmi les
critères de sélection la présence d'une
pharmacie ou le savez vous l'avez
mentionné c'est une offre de service
minimal essentiel j'entends aussi que
certaines communes s'inquiètent de pas
pouvoir satisfaire aux exigences posées
par la nouvelle réglementation motive
qu'elle dispose pas de pharmacie je
pense qu'on peut trouver un compromis
pour un équilibre entre la réalité des
communes et le maintien d'une offre
touristique de qualité je vais donc
proposer une réunion aux élus je suggère
de vous y convier bien entendu en
octobre pour une réflexion sur une
réforme plus globale des critères de
classement en lien avec d'autres
ministères concernés et je pense
notamment bien sûr au ministère de la
transition écologique mais aussi au
ministère de la Santé et des Solidarités
on doit pouvoir trouver des solutions et
maintenir le classement des communes
touristiques qui le méritent je poursuis
après le sénateur Laurent le ski un
sujet majeur j'ai eu l'honneur d'être un
domaine skiable de France vendredi
je veux saluer la responsabilité des
acteurs qui se sont alignés pour
atteindre des objectifs de sobriété 10%
et qui seront au cœur d'ailleurs de la
présentation du 6 octobre prochain les
acteurs du ski
dans le groupe de travail donc sur la
sobriété énergétique des engagements
forts ont été pris
sur le coup de l'électricité les
stations et on les accompagne sont
éligibles aux aides résilience
résilience on a un sujet sur lequel nous
sommes en ce moment même en train de
travailler donc à votre disposition vous
avez un sujet précis lié au régie je
suis pas du genre à laisser la poussière
sur le tapis donc si vous avez un sujet
de régie on travaille dessus et c'est un
des sujets que je n'ai pas encore résolu
mais on va y arriver et on va se battre
en tout cas je veux saluer le la
responsabilité des acteurs du ski
sur
la sénatrice Artigalas vous m'avez
questionné sur le tourisme de proximité
le tourisme durable aussi puisque la
proximité est par nature durable du
moins moins énergivore
pour un chiffre que je partage avec vous
c'est intéressant la filière tourisme
serait selon l'ADEME à l'origine de 11%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
France la transition durable du tourisme
est donc un enjeu majeur les acteurs en
sont parfaitement conscients
l'accompagnement de l'évolution de
l'offre touristique est au coeur du du
plan de relance tourisme notamment mais
aussi du plan destination France 1 le
fond tourisme durable destiné à
accompagner la transition des acteurs du
tourisme dans les territoires peu denses
et à développer des formes de tourisme
plus responsables je pense notamment au
slow tourisme ou à le notorise ou à la
grille tourisme le font tourisme durable
toujours
disponible et le fond à venir montagne
lui aussi qui fait le lien avec la
question précédente liée au ski le fond
à venir montagne qui était doté de 330 4
millions d'euros
qui vise à accélérer la diversification
la transition des écologiques des
activités de tourisme et de montagne et
lui en train d'être décaissé donc cette
injecté aujourd'hui même au cœur de
notre tourisme mais ce plan est déployé
sur nos territoires et au sein du plan
destination France doté de 1,9 milliards
d'euros il y a un dispositif budgétaire
à 44 millions d'euros pour soutenir
l'investissement dans les
infrastructures touristiques durables je
suggère là aussi pour ne pas être trop
longue si vous l'acceptez madame la
sénatrice et que vous avez quelques
sujets de liés à votre circonscription
peut-être qu'on s'en reparle avec ma
conseillère au fond en charge des sujets
tourisme le tourisme mérite bien qu'on y
passe un peu plus de temps si vous avez
des exemples concrets qui sur lesquels
il nous faudrait investir sénateur
MÉRILLON
j'avais bien écrit c'est je m'autorise
mal c'est le signe de la fatigue
pardonnez-moi monsieur le sénateur
demain matin à 8h30 à Bercy on passe une
bonne partie de la matinée avec les
fournisseurs d'énergie on a une charte
une charte d'engagement qui va être
discuté qui va être signé je pense qu'on
va pouvoir et je l'espère obtenir
quelques avancées
oserais-je vous dire que je recommande
quelque chose qui est entre l'expression
de la présidente de la creux et
l'expression de mon cher ministre de
tutelle et de mon très cher Président de
la République c'est-à-dire peut-être
d'attendre la fin de la semaine on a ce
deuxième conseil sur lequel on a encore
beaucoup de d'espoir après si vous avez
une situation sur laquelle vous n'avez
pas d'option et que ça ne souffre pas 72
heures d'attente là aussi on a mobilisé
avec Bruno Le Maire Bruno Le Maire a
mobilisé la médiation de l'énergie qui
intervient
sur certaines renégociations donc si
vous avez des exemples concrets
d'entreprises qui doivent renégocier
pour des raisons de prod dans les jours
qui viennent et que ça ne souffre pas 72
heures ou une semaine la médiation
intervient pour vérifier le caractère de
nabusif des offres faites ou et les
caractères raisonnables des offres
alternatives je suis en mesure de la
mobiliser je suis pas sûr que ce soit de
la cacophonie il peut arriver dans ces
moments qui est un peu de polyphonie et
j'en prends une partie de la charge ça
fait partie du des de la difficulté du
moment
sénatrice blaix
pardon j'écris vraiment mal les
associations de consommateurs
je suis très sensible aux réflexions
engagées sur le mouvement que je
méristes en France qui selon moi très
clairement doit être modernisé
c'est un objectif avec lequel je suis
très en ligne et ce depuis des années
puisque là aussi au sein du rapport 134
à la commission des finances lorsque
j'étais député j'y avais travaillé ça
fait maintenant de nombreuses années
qu'on sait et que tous ensemble
d'ailleurs élus comme membres du
gouvernement on appelle le mouvement
consumériste à se moderniser et on a
aussi une époque qui suppose des
nouveaux modes de consommation et donc
le mouvement consumériste doit pouvoir
suivre et ce moderniser le rapport
d'information qui a été réalisé duquel
vous étiez parti prenante apporte à ces
dégâts des pistes que je trouve très
intéressantes je pense par exemple que
le financement en public que vous avez
suggéré de prioritairement dirigé vers
les associations dont la présence
territoriale est significative est une
bonne recommandation
je vais vous dire aussi que la DGCCRF en
ce moment même est en train de consulter
les associations de consommateurs sur
les pistes d'évolution envisageables à
partir d'ailleurs du rapport réalisé par
les sénateurs mais aussi du rapport de
la Cour des comptes d'octobre 2021 je
vais vous dire que les premières
analyses vont remonter très vite côté
DGCCRF et que j'aurai plaisir à vous
informer que je vais réunir autour d'une
même table à Bercy les associations de
consommateurs d'ici la fin de l'année
pour recueillir leur proposition pour
enrichir le travail du Gouvernement en
la matière et avancer les accompagner et
prendre des positions un peu fortes à
votre disposition pour vous informer de
la date de la tenue de cette réunion et
peut-être même vous y conviez dans le
cadre des travaux que vous avez réalisés
avec le sénateur gay et la sénatrice
fera
je vais pas revenir sur les fragues mais
sachez que je je suis totalement
d'accord avec ce que vous avez dit et je
ne saurais que trop vous encourager à
les recevoir pour les auditionner pour
vous assurer que les indicateurs de
l'ephrague sont à hauteur de PME ou en
tout cas de d'entreprise humaine ça a
été mon sujet pendant deux ans je
connais assez bien monsieur dumières et
pas du mien de kambour et son engagement
au cœur de l'ephrague sur ces sujets
d'indicateurs je pense que c'est très
important que les élus suivent de près
les indicateurs qui sont en train d'être
façonnés pour la partie environnementale
possible côté et frag votre souci est
légitime sur le commerce extérieur c'est
mon homologue Olivier best qui est à la
manœuvre si vous pensez que les PME sont
pas assez intégrés dans France Export
dites le moi moi j'ai le sentiment que
pour l'instant la team France Export
marche plutôt bien mais peut-être
faut-il renforcer la présence de nos
petites et moyennes entreprises donc à
votre disposition pour échanger
là-dessus
gaker je prends le document de la
présidente qui est bien mieux décrit que
le mien la main d'oeuvre
oui c'est aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de voir que
vous parlez quasiment autant d'énergie
que de main d'oeuvre ce sont aujourd'hui
les deux préoccupations qui donnent des
insomnies à nos entrepreneurs c'est une
situation que j'ai dont j'ai hérité en
arrivant j'ai donc passé mon été ce qui
me permet aussi d'en dire un mot à
l'endroit de monsieur grémier qui a posé
la question sur la main d'oeuvre
notamment dans hôtellerie commerce
restauration
on a plusieurs types de problèmes on a
des problèmes très très chauds avec les
saisonniers en réalité corrélés vous
avez été nombreux à le dire au logement
et à la mobilité j'ai fait assez de
déplacements cet été pour voir que la
question de la seule rémunération
notamment des saisonniers n'étaient pas
l'alpha et l'oméga du problème nous
avons un sujet d'attractivité mais pas
que d'attractivité on a un sujet
d'organisation de la vie du saisonnier
avec des locations touristiques vous
avez soulevé le sujet à des prix qui
sont complètement impossibles pour les
saisonniers donc on a fait comme on a pu
je vais pas vous mentir avec mon
collègue Olivier du soft on a mobilisé
les préfets en a mobilisé les rectorats
on a mobilisé les résidences
universitaires cet été pour pouvoir
parvenir à le GD des saisonniers il faut
qu'on arrive à trouver des solutions il
y a pas mal de de d'irritons sur
lesquels je suis en train de travailler
avec l'URSSAF notamment pour les
entrepreneurs je pense aux hôteliers aux
restaurateurs par exemple qui ont des
espaces dans lesquels ils pourraient
aménager qui démobilots ou des espaces
pour loger leur saisonnier il y a pas
mal de traquestrie administrative qui
les en empêche donc je suis en train de
regarder ce sujet très précisément au
niveau de l'URSSAF notamment pour
permettre aussi aux hôteliers aux
restaurateurs s'ils le souhaitent voient
héberger leur saisonniers ce qui
réduirait le problème aussi de la
mobilité c'est un sujet sur lequel on
est plusieurs membres du gouvernement à
agir en lien avec les préfets et sur
lequel j'ai espoir qu'on avance plus
largement sur HCR je vais quand même
vous dire notamment au sénateur
Gremillet
que le gouvernement a déjà mis en place
un certain nombre de choses on a 200 000
besoins de recrutement estimés dans le
hôtellerie commerce restauration vous le
savez lui a augmenté de 16% la branche a
augmenté de 16%
les salaires c'était nécessaire est-ce
que ce sera suffisant un palier ce
manque de main d'oeuvre qui est criant
et qui n'est pas d'ailleurs nouveau
qu'on découvre pas il y a des enjeux de
qualité aussi de vie au travail il y a
des enjeux de conciliation vie pro vie
personnelle il y a des enjeux aussi de
mutation de salariés notamment des
jeunes générations c'est compliqué comme
sujet et en l'occurrence le gouvernement
a mis en place
un plan qui a été doté quand même d'un
virgule 4 milliards d'euros à l'automne
dernier c'était alors Elisabeth borne
ministre du Travail qui l'avait annoncé
ce plan a permis ce plan des métiers
sous tension a permis de remettre vers
le chemin de l'emploi sur les métiers au
son en sous tension pardonnez-moi
notamment dans l'hôtellerie le commerce
et la restauration un peu plus de 280
000 chômeurs de longue durée qui était
éloignée de l'emploi et on a réussi très
précisément dans les métiers HCR depuis
un an à en former à remplacer 80 000
donc vous me direz 80000 sur les 200000
il y a encore beaucoup de travail mais
on se bat on a mis beaucoup d'argent en
tout cas l'argent nécessaire pour
permettre une formation accélérée des
chômeurs de longue durée vers ces
métiers sous tension je ne peux pas en
toute honnêteté ne pas aborder en un mot
aussi la réforme de l'assurance chômage
que nous porterons au Parlement dans les
prochaines semaines et qui doit aussi
encourager au retour à l'emploi un
certain nombre de nos chômeurs de longue
durée qui plus est sous des sur des
métiers
en tension
est-ce que j'ai oublié
je si si j'oublie plein de choses
sénateurs
salmon sur les meubles les touristiques
alors j'ai une fiche quelque part nous
voilà la voilà
meublé touristique on a vu les
propositions sur la fiscalité pour les
locations meublées dans le cas du PLF
nous sommes en train de regarder très
attentivement les pistes possibles pour
renforcer cette fiscalité
voilà je pense que ma réponse est claire
je fais attention à une chose
les effets de bord
notamment sur nos gîtes
auxquels nous tenons je pense toutes et
tous
et en même temps sur notre capacité
d'accueil des je l'espère allez millions
dizaines de millions de touristes qui
vont venir dans notre beau pays
si ce n'est voir du rugby l'année
prochaine ou voir des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques en 2024 donc il y a un
enjeu d'équilibre aussi sur possiblement
un renforcement possible de cette
fiscalité possiblement ce seront les
débats parlementaires qui qui dans le
trancheront sans que ça n'impacte des
gîtes on parlait tourisme durable et de
proximité on parlait TPME nos gîtes en
sont et sans que ça noblitaire nos
capacités d'accueil à la hauteur de
notre tradition touristique en France
dans les prochaines années mais c'est un
sujet sur lequel nous aurons l'occasion
de reparler durant le PLF
pour terminer Monsieur le Sénateur
Châtillon
alors je vais prendre la tâche du
sénateur Châtillon sur l'entreprise qui
la mentionné quant aux impôts de
production
j'aurais à coeur de lui adresser une
réponse écrite et peut-être de voir s'il
souhaite qu'on en parle avec le ministre
du budget des comptes publics je vous
remercie
si Madame la Ministre alors il y a un
petit bonus parce que Vincent Segoin me
demande une minute mais c'est vraiment
une minute Vincent et Jean-Marc aussi
alors vite parce que on est voilà madame
la ministre a un rendez-vous et nous
aussi allez Vincent
vraiment une minute c'est vraiment sympa
Madame le Ministre juste je vous écoute
déjà depuis depuis un bon moment
je voulais revenir sur le DEF vous dites
le gouvernement va intervenir pour
essayer de de d'éviter des surinflation
et j'en passe mais vous n'avez pas de
sentiment que vous êtes à l'origine de
la création de la pénurie avec EDF
puisque les centrales ne fonctionnent
qu'à 65%. en même temps je vous entends
dire il faut on verse des subventions
pour que les entreprises soient toujours
plus propres les entreprises toujours
plus propres des subventions d'argent
public donc on crée de la demande
supplémentaire
vous n'avez pas l'impression qu'il y a
un effet de ciseaux
ma question c'est simple est-ce qu'on va
continuer de gérer la France de la sorte
à répondre plus cette idéologie
qu'à faire des calculs d'impact et puis
à gérer comme une entreprise on peut
gérer
c'était ma première question
et j'arrête là
mais je trouve que l'argent public le
déversement de l'argent public ne fait
que de créer des problèmes allez
Jean-Marc rapidement et après c'est tout
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre tout à l'heure si j'ai bien
compris vous avez
annoncé que le tourisme était
responsable de 17% des émissions de CO2
11 11% des missions de CO2 alors
quels éléments objectifs permettent
d'affirmer une chose pareille parce que
aujourd'hui enfin moi j'habite à la
montagne je vois le tourisme montagnard
toute l'année et j'ai vraiment pas
l'impression que aujourd'hui le tourisme
ne soit pas éco-responsable comme on dit
puisque aujourd'hui c'est des
expressions qu'on emploie couramment
durable ou en vertueux donc
et on est sur des secteurs qui sont en
plein essor touristique et je crois que
je ne vois pas
honnêtement je ne vois pas où sont les
émissions de CO2 produite par l'activité
touristique actuellement dans son autre
territoire je veux qu'on m'explique
concrètement ce que ça veut dire d'être
éco-responsable vertueux et
durable voilà
allez madame la ministre la question
courte des gourmandises oui écoutez je
vais pas bouder mon plaisir vu que je
suis gourmand de scie monsieur Segoin si
nous avions organisé la pénurie nous
serions les seuls à être touchés
il vous a pas échappé que la situation
énergétique frappe l'Europe entière
et quand en l'occurrence
pardonnez-moi je vais me permettre juste
de vous répondre il vous a pas échappé
non plus que je même si on peut se
ressembler je ne suis pas agnier
espagnol une haché en fait si vous
m'écoutez pas je veux pas vous répondre
ce sera plus simple
et écoutez je
pardon
donc je pense que il y a eu c'est aussi
une situation sur laquelle on est qui
est c'est des années des années de choix
politiques notamment en matière
nucléaire nous n'avons pas en
l'occurrence on a eu plusieurs
gouvernements qui ont pris des positions
depuis de longues années nous avons
aujourd'hui une situation énergétique
qui est plus tendue que d'autres pays
européens j'en suis bien consciente pour
autant je pense que nous faisons et nous
continuons à nous battre pour obtenir
des aménagements pour les entreprises
françaises après je vais vous dire on
sera pas d'accord monsieur le sénateur
Ségouin vous vivez la transition
écologique comme un fardeau je le vis
comme bah si vous parlez de dépenses
publiques il faut qu'on ait un dialogue
j'accuse de rien monsieur c'est pas mon
genre en plus non alors je vais le dire
autrement vous pensez que la transition
écologique est une dépense je pense que
c'est un investissement vous parlez
d'argent qu'on gêne par les fenêtres moi
je ne viens pas du mouvement écologique
je viens de la vraie vie j'étais
entrepreneur je ne suis beaucoup moins
calé non mais j'ai pas une pratique et
une connaissance extrêmement aussi calée
que celle et ceux qui sont engagés
depuis des années sur ces enjeux-là
maintenant je pense effectivement que
c'est une obligation pour nous toutes et
nous tous si vous estimez qu'accompagner
nos entreprises mettre de l'argent dans
le diagnostic de nos entreprises c'est
pardonnez-moi des dépenses indues et
jeter de l'argent par les fenêtres c'est
le sens de votre deuxième intervention
si Monsieur et ben on sera pas d'accord
là-dessus voilà je suis désolé de vous
le dire donc voilà par ailleurs monsieur
voyez
là aussi je pense que les prix de
l'énergie sont en haut à cause d'une
crise mondiale les problèmes
sont des je n'arrive pas à lire ce que
tu m'écris donc je vais dire ce que je
pense sera plus simple je pense qu'on
hérite d'une situation qui est
compliquée et que on va faire ce qu'il
faut et s'il faut que ça qu'on continue
à investir on va le faire et s'il y a
quelques dépenses publiques on le fera
autant pour moi l'empreinte carbone du
tourisme et ben je vais vous envoyer le
rapport de l'ADEME sur les 11% parce que
je n'ai que des propos qui sont étayés
sur les 11% des missions de gaz à effet
de serre je vous dirai ce que j'ai dit
au patron de domaine skiable de France
vendredi ça n'est pas parce qu'on dit
qu'on fait 11 % des missions de gaz à
effet de serre qu'on est pas responsable
au plan environnemental c'est une
réalité il y a la mobilité toutes celles
et ceux qui viennent au ski il y a des
dépenses énergétiques il y a le damage
il y a sais-tu aujourd'hui une nécessité
et en fait il y a rien de stigmatisant
je reprends exactement le même mot que
j'ai eu d'ailleurs dans une expression
très claire avec les acteurs du ski et
de domaine skiable de France l'ensemble
des secteurs touristiques sont en train
de faire le mutation le surtourisme sur
le littoral est un sujet que les acteurs
du littoral sont en train d'adresser il
y a des sujets relatifs au domaine
skiable j'ai eu l'occasion de promouvoir
le ski des quatre saisons pour le coup
et je pense qu'on il y a aucune
stigmatisation dans le fait de rappeler
qu'il y a aussi de la de l'émission
carbone dans nos domaines skiables et
dans le tourisme au ski il y a aucune
stigmatisation ça peut ne pas vous
plaire mais c'est pourtant étayer et
fonder et c'est ben oui mais en fait
c'est plutôt enfin c'est pas grave on a
tous on est tous responsables des
missions de gaz à effet de serre les
consommateurs comme les acteurs donc il
faut qu'on se batte ensemble
voilà très bien merci merci beaucoup
madame la ministre pour ces réponses
voilà qui ont été précises sur les
sujets qui sont les vôtres et qui
renvoient un certain nombre de
ministères pour celles vous êtes très en
retard nous aussi donc merci beaucoup
d'avoir passé ce temps avec nous merci